keep going
so
okay some uh
beginner points okay
so you're pushing
and it's just going into my back foot
okay
and my first thing i want to do is
establish that ground thinking is it
it's a center to center connection you
keep keep pushing right and i don't want
to
disconnect my organization
watch what happens before you get my
balance go ahead and go and see how i
started
leaning like that okay
so instead as he goes
i just keep
those corners there just keep them there
okay
and the second thing i'm going to do you
can keep it
the second thing i'm going to do is not
just turn my body
like that okay
i'm going to take that energy and move
it onto the back leg you see that a
weight shift you're pushing
and i go into a yawn phase on the back
leg and that's what keep pushing
okay
that nope you have to do the other hand
that leg is what i turn my whole leg
so i'll do it differently you see i'm
broken here do you see that and before i
fall over i turn my
waist and we're not going to do that
okay
i'm he's going to push
i keep those four corners structure
going to a young phase on the leg you're
pushing and that's what he's pushing and
that's what i turn okay
go again
and then i want to time it with his push
and see how i did that okay here i was
showing his static but when he comes to
push
into the leg
okay
let's try to go relax less energy okay
let go
you're gonna shift your weight
onto the back foot so that the knee goes
over the toes right now it's too far
not that far
knees over toes is young face okay
go back shift your weight forward
and then go again
knee over toe
and one more time
again
and keep this arch up okay don't let it
go down
all right go back
and now when you're just going to use
one fingertip when he pushes you
that's when you shift onto that
pushes you
onto that spot arch up don't let the
arch kick in
okay now we'll do it with the grip with
a little less pressure
more pushes
you absorb there
okay you can increase the pressure and
you let him push you into that note you
raise against him
let him push you onto that leg
more
there and again
go
cool all right so
i don't know if you saw
but
right when it got really hard to push
and you got tired and wanted to change
arms is actually when i go to that young
face in here it's kind of easy you feel
that
when i go to the yawn face
we're not going anywhere okay you got it
so
you have to have faith in beyond faith
okay let it push you onto it and not you
pushing back into him
don't worry about one leg that's just to
make the point
go back
shift arch up knee over toes
and again
into that state there you go and now
you turn
okay come back and we're going to do
that all together
and now you're turning okay let's try it
again
okay so he pushes me onto that leg and
as i culminate that boom i turn him okay
we'll stay in the chicken okay
uh
what i do here is i create
an entering angle do you think
so
if i let him shift to here and he stays
here
it's not good enough
he has to
pass
to here you see that you get that okay
so he pushes whoa whoa there it is right
there and now you can just walk into
that angle okay
boom there it is and now you can just
step into this zone so let me have
tristan come so you can see what i'm
talking about
okay
well not enough he's blocking my edemi
angle okay
he has to come further
and now i can walk straight into this
piecing and we're going to just
literally walk into it and stand there
okay
he's in whoa
boom there it is right there okay so he
has to pass you do you understand
not here
he is going to be behind me
once i start turning daisy
[Music]
then you can just walk straight into
that ankle okay i know that's not the
technique but we want to see that my
whole body could fit in there okay let's
try it
so i go here
and i don't want him here because he's
in my way you see that
more importantly for tai no henko if i
try to step behind him
instead of where
he is now
this hand will come near my body you see
that and now my deltoid is part of the
fight and deltoid should never be part
of the fight okay
so he has to go past
me do you see
and if i can get the left shoulder in
i can always get the right shoulder in
so that's why we did that drill okay
so now we're gonna go back to the right
shoulder whoa
[Music]
my right shoulder is in play okay
and that's what i want you to think of
so the same homologous shoulder here it
is
don't step and crush your arm turn a
little bit this way don't step and crush
your arm
you're going to step on the curve and
your right shoulder is going to go right
behind your shoulder
oh
stay on the earth and now our shoulders
are matching each other can you see that
again
stay on a curb if he's there when i
enter my shoulder will match his
shoulder
slightly behind it
okay
just
i'm going to put my shoulder right
behind his shoulder roll on that
okay
this
[Music]
okay
let's pay attention to that lead
shoulder go
so we know
bring them past you
and then
enter on the turn so your shoulder
starts to get here
right
and
first i'm going to do the pull so you
understand what i'm doing feel it in
your fingertips okay
you feel that pull okay
and then next i'm going to do the twist
that some of you are doing
you see that and then
okay
that means your four corners are not
organized okay
so
why does it happen
okay let me use tristan so you can watch
it
did you all feel it
it happens because
when you're entering
you are double pivoting when you turn
or you're putting your foot here
and your two feet are turning
like this
you see
and now
your axis of rotation
is actually over here
and it's not where the shoulder is so
your axis of rotation is actually in
front of him
do you understand that
john
okay you guys about that
and that would have been like not in
training at all
once you start turning and when you
enter you won't notice it but when you
start turning it starts falling apart
okay
so
we'll go at this angle please over here
he comes in i go to my yawn state in the
rotation
and it's from that young state
that this foot is not uh double weighted
it's a single weighted foot until i come
back onto it and go to a young state in
this foot this means my knees are over
my toes you see so we'll just stay there
i'm going to go
one
and two and the rotation is on that foot
now not between the two feet okay
so
yawn
insert
and yawn again on that one foot
enter
and yawn all the way onto that foot so
you have a single pivot point on that
one foot
there's the gap
boom establish this single pivot point
that single pivot point
boom
double do you see
and now when you attend con you're back
in front of him
right
behind him
single pivot point behind him
all of your tank on happens
after the eddy boom that's it
this foot now goes straight back
does not
arc
twist
okay
it goes straight back
all of the turns happens here
you're just resting there okay
let's try it